as we start then with breaking news an
11 year old girl who disappeared from
her home in bolton
has been found police say that fatouma
khadir traveled to london
alone in the early hours of yesterday
morning well straight to jemima walker
in the newsroom with more on this so
jemima what more do we know
yes so in the last few moments really a
family friend of the kadir family has
told sky news
that she has been found safe and well in
london so we are waiting
for confirmation from the police but a
family friend has told us that she's
been found
they say that she's with police officers
and she hasn't yet spoken to the family
and this news comes really just moments
after fatima's parents and police
gave an interview to reporters really
still
you know pleading for her any for any
information pleading for her to come
home
to just let them know she's safe so this
has all happened very very recently
and in that interview the parents were
asked had she seemed normal what was
going on and they said
everything had seemed completely fine
she was in the kitchen chatting to them
before she left
but they said that information that was
kind of emerging
was that she had a real interest in
sightseeing in london
so the parents say they didn't really
know this but her younger brother said
that this is something he knew and then
they started looking at her school books
and this interest in sightseeing and
going to the tower of london and going
to buckingham palace
started to emerge and that was something
that was confirmed
by dci paul rollinson when he was in the
press conference and obviously one of
the kind of
questions around this is how did an 11
year old girl
get from london on thursday evening she
was last seen in bolton
arrived in london at 1am just after 1am
how did she get there how did nobody
stop an 11 year old girl but what was
emerging is that she
told people that she'd seen a couple on
the train for example that she was 15
years old and that she was going to
visit her aunt in tower bridge and
people that had spoken to her and then
spoken to the police
said that this information was quite
convincing really and although they
thought it was a little bit strange
this story was convincing enough that
she managed to
get to london without anybody really
being too alarmed the other question
obviously as well is where did she sleep
because she went missing on thursday
evening
it is now saturday but the police say
that she did have a substantial amount
of money with her so she could have
booked herself in a hotel
another question obviously is why didn't
she contact anybody the police say that
they believe
her phone may have been broken because
they think
she asked a woman in london if she could
hotspot off her phone so
a lot of questions still obviously
surrounding this but
very good news for her family in the
press conference that they just gave
they were extremely emotional her father
broke down in tears so
this news justin very good news for
everybody involved